[Music]
Donald Trump a man this outspoken
doesn't need scriptwriters so we just
used his actual quotes see Trump in his
own words starring Jack McBrayer is that
I'm very rich
born into humble surroundings goo goo
I have never seen a thin person drinking
diet coke go girl
he quickly rose through the ranks and
the family business
sorry how you losers and haters but my
IQ is one of the highest and you all
know it and soon he became the
definition of success my fingers are
long and beautiful as it has been
well-documented are various other parts
of my body
he found loved and lost it I just can't
take it anymore I have a great
relationship with the blacks
he even conquered Hollywood hosting the
most popular show to ever have the word
apprentice in its title I've said if
Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps I'd
be dating her you may want to stop
talking and get straight to the firing
point okay Coolio you're fired his is a
journey that just might end up in the
White House Arianna Huffington is
unattractive both inside and out I fully
understand why her former husband left
her for a man he made a good decision
Jack McBrayer is Donald Trump in Trump
in his own words coming soon to TBS
somebody's doing the raping
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]